[Música]
olá sou um sonhador professores
empreendedor e uma decisão mudou a minha
vida em 15 minutos passar por algumas
fronteiras são decisões racionais
já por outras são obra do acaso ou da
nossa fé determinar o que é destino
sorte coerência ou incoerência não
caberia next
mesmo que a gente tivesse 90 minutos
mais prorrogação
hoje eu vou contar para vocês como essa
visão ou a casa mudou a minha vida
fez com que eu vivenciasse outras
fronteiras e fizeram de mim um ser
humano melhor
o dia é 26 de dezembro no longínquo ano
de 2004 naquele dia tudo parecia muito
tropical muito tranquilo muito verão o
dia nascendo pássaros cantando e até
violinos sozinha na tv alegando fazer
olhamos um para o outro tentando
entender o que passava e chegamos à
conclusão que ninguém havia sequer
passar do próximo da tv
o controle remoto lá parado intocável
desafiava a nossa imaginação
aquilo não fazia o mínimo sentido na
tela
só aquele chuvisco clássico de
tvs com turbo tvs como tuba boa parte de
vocês não sabem do que eu estou falando
mas enfim mesmo com inusitado mesmo como
a estranheza daquilo
quem liga estamos de férias na tailândia
a programação do dia destino imediato
pedi porque imaginem as férias dos
sonhos
chegando no píer aquele ambiente de
tranquilidade de felicidade muita gente
barraquinhas de artesanato local com
tons de madeira muitas coisas muita
vaidade boa e é isso que no meio de toda
essa e se agita essa tranquilidade
uma cena chama atenção o menino
olhando o mar esse menino tinha no seu
olhar uma angústia uma tristeza que nos
chamou muito a atenção
pensamos vamos até lá vamos comprar
alguns biscoitos e refrigerante e tentar
minimizar essa situação
esse menino recebeu essas gostosuras e
simplesmente olhava mar triste mas enfim
voltando ao nosso passeio
saímos para evitar a primeira das ilhas
no roteiro ou pedir por exemplo uma
espécie de cartão-postal o clássico de
qualquer turista em terra as tailandesas
durante os primeiros 30 minutos
brincadeira
risadas e passa muita massa chegando a
primeira das ilhas
alguma coisa já acontecia
aquele mar antes transparente
translúcido em azul agora uma combinação
de azul e marrom que não fazia muito
sentido para os surfistas de plantão
diriam que nossa omar ele também está
muito mexido
enquanto a gente tentava descobrir o que
estava acontecendo
o comandante do nosso barco recebe uma
mensagem por rádio
seu semblante antes de tranquilidade de
segurança passa a ser um semblante de
preocupação e agitação
não entendemos muito bem o que acontecia
mas um gesto em especial nos deixou
muito preocupados
esse comandante uma espécie de tubarão
local brasil dever pega evert o seu
colete salva vidas e anuncia naquele
momento um tsunami de grau delas
atingindo toda orla de porque momento de
incredulidade
não sabemos aqui sentir o que pensar
olhando para o levante é isso que se
apresenta navio da marinha tailandesa
a suntuosidade do navio dá o tom da
situação
somos obrigados a ir à morte
e aguardar por orientações aqui nesse
momento uma primeira fronteira se
manifesta de forma com um contundente é
a fronteira da distância da fronteira da
amizade uma amiga na bélgica liga para o
meu celular
ela pergunta onde vocês estão o que está
acontecendo e eu respondo não faço a
mínima ideia estamos em alto mar
nesse momento ela revela uma outra
fronteira uma fronteira do determinismo
definitiva
ela fala de uma fronteira de vítima de
25 mil pessoas
é uma informação que bate de uma maneira
absurda
ficamos num em alto mar até o final do
dia
angústia incerteza não se sabe o que
pensar
ao final do dia recebemos a informação
de que iríamos retornar á o que antes
éra o pia de porque a confirmação
recebida modo antes de voltar ela é
impactante o mesmo pia do qual saímos às
9 e 16
jean foi destruído pela onda às 9 e 31
em sair os meus 15 minutos da minha fé
do meu determinismo do meu acaso
chegando ao piano
o que antes era festa felicidade e boa
energia
agora era dezena de guerra o caos e
destruição
destroços de casas carros retorcidos
enfim destroços de vida e eu só lembrava
daquele menino correr sob a caçamba de
um caminhão andor medo insegurança tudo
mobilizando a fronteira da sobrevivência
fronteira da limitação humana
somos então levados até um ponto pra
sermos deslocados a locais mais altos
e aí indo em direção a esse local um
campo da cruz vermelha se apresenta
nesse campo da cruz vermelha medo
cansaço e insegurança são todos
colocados de lado para que a fronteira
da colaboração à fronteira da cooperação
na fronteira da sobrevivência seja
levamos
foram três dias trabalhando auxiliando
junto com outras pessoas junto com
heróis desconhecidos fazendo que poucos
faziam falando o que ninguém gostaria de
te falar
mobilizando a essência mais colaborativa
do que é ser humano o que o navio pra
vocês é o tsunami de 2004 que impactou
11 baianas no sudeste da ásia vitimando
227.898 pessoas
este evento
quando eu olho pra trás
quando eu visito o alexandre prédios
unami aquele cara abduzido pela
velocidade do dia pela loucura do mundo
corporativo pela pelo distanciamento por
assim dizer com algum propósito mais
reflectivo de vida
eu não reconheço aquele cara e esse
ressignificado a partir do evento me
escolher me fez escolher um novo caminho
esse evento é o meu ponto da virada de
buscar uma orientação mais empreendedora
mais propositivo que por vezes possamos
a arriscar um pouco mais nos colocar em
situações onde vamos superar nossas
limitações romper algumas fronteiras
que possamos brincar com a sua nova
atividade e com a nossa criatividade
para entregar um valor melhor à
sociedade as pessoas que possamos
despertar aquela gana de fazer as coisas
acontecerem porque o mundo precisa que
as coisas aconteçam
e esse é o meu novo caminho ser um pouco
mais empreendedor ser um pouco mais
propositivo romper essa fronteira onde
por vezes somos muito mais reativos do
que propositivos ser humano melhor
então o que eu deixo aqui hoje é talvez
uma inquietação de que não precisamos
aguardar por uma grande onda não
precisamos aguardar por e simplesmente
por um acaso que impacta a nossa vida e
que resignifica que ela em vez de
aguardar por um evento que possamos ter
nós eu e você
esse novo evento muito mais propositivo
muito mais colaborativo e com certeza
rompendo várias fronteiras
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]